AND GREG.
IT'S 5:00 IN NEW YORK CITY AND
THIS IS "THE FIVE" ."
MEDIA BIAS EXPOSED.
IT IS NO SURPRISE THAT THE
LEFT-WING MEDIA HATES
PRESIDENT TRUMP BUT THIS NEXT
STORY MIGHT BE ONE OF THEM ARE
GROTESQUELY IRRESPONSIBLE
EXAMPLES YET.
DURING YESTERDAY'S SANCTUARY
STATE ROUNDTABLE THE PRESIDENT
WAS ASKED ABOUT THE DANGEROUS
MS-13 GANG.
WATCH.
>> IF THEY DON'T REACH EIGHT
CERTAIN THRESHOLD, I CANNOT TELL
I.C.E. ABOUT THEM.
>> WE HAVE PEOPLE COMING INTO
THE COUNTRY, TRYING TO COME IN,
OR STOPPING A LOT OF THEM.
YOU WOULDN'T BELIEVE HOW BAD
THESE PEOPLE ARE.
THESE AREN'T PEOPLE.
THESE ARE ANIMALS.
WE ARE TAKING THEM OUT OF THE
COUNTRY AT A LEVEL AND RATE
THAT'S NEVER HAPPENED BEFORE.
>> Jesse: THE MAINSTREAM PRESS
INCLUDING "THE NEW YORK TIMES,"
"USA TODAY," "WASHINGTON POST"
AND OTHERS TOOK TRUMP OUT OF
CONTEXT, SUGGESTING HE CALLED
ALL OF THE ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS
ANIMALS, NOT JUST MS-13.
THE MORNING PAPERS FLAT OUT
MISLEADING READERS WITH
HEADLINES LIKE THIS FROM
"THE NEW YORK TIMES."
"TRUMP CALLS SOME UNAUTHORIZED
IMMIGRANTS ANIMALS IN RAMP."
FROM "USA TODAY," "TRUMP CALLS
UNDOCUMENTED PEOPLE ANIMALS,
RHETORIC WITH A DARK PAST."
THE PRESIDENT ADDRESSING THE
OUTRAGEOUS REPORTS.
>> YOU KNOW I AM REFERRING TO
THE MS-13 GANGS THAT ARE COMING
IN.
I WAS TALKING ABOUT THE MS-13
AND ALSO IF YOU LOOK A LITTLE
BIT FURTHER ON THE TAPE, YOU
WILL SEE WE HAVE LAWS.
ONE MS-13 COMES IN AND OTHER
GANG MEMBERS COMING, I REFER TO
THEM AS ANIMALS.
GUESS WHAT.
I ALWAYS WILL.
WE ARE GETTING THEM OUT BY THE
THOUSANDS.
IT'S A BIG DANGEROUS JOB, AND
THEY ARE ABLE IN SOME CASES TO
COME BACK AND OR NEW GROUPS COME
IN, ALSO FROM THE GANGS.
>> Jesse: SARAH SANDERS
ISSUING THIS EPIC TAKEDOWN OF
THE LIBERAL TRUMP HEATING MEDIA.
>> THE PRESIDENT WAS CLEARLY
REFERRING TO MS-13 GANG MEMBERS.
THEY ENTER THE COUNTRY ILLEGALLY
AND WHOSE DEPORTATIONS ARE
HAMSTRUNG BY OUR LAWS.
THIS IS ONE OF THE MOST VICIOUS
AND DEADLY GANGS THAT OPERATE BY
THE MOTTO OF "RAPE, KILL,
CONTROL."
I DON'T THINK THE TERM THE
PRESIDENT USE WAS STRONG ENOUGH.
MS-13 HAS DONE HEINOUS ACTS.
IT TOOK AN ANIMAL TO STAB A MAN
100 TIMES, RIPPED HIS HEART OUT.
IT TOOK AN ANIMAL TO KIDNAP,
DRUGGED AND A 14-YEAR-OLD
HOUSTON GIRL.
I THINK THE TERM ANIMAL DOESN'T
GO FAR ENOUGH.
>> Jesse: DAY NOW, THIS IS
DEVASTATING FOR THE MAINSTREAM
MEDIA.
THIS WASN'T A FEW OUTLETS.
THESE WERE THE BIGGEST, MOST
CREDIBLE MEDIA COMPANIES OUT
THERE BOTCHING THING THAT'S
PRETTY SIMPLE.
>> Dana: IT GREW BECAUSE OF
SOCIAL MEDIA.
I REMEMBER THERE WERE TIMES
WHEN, AND EDITOR HERE IN
NEW YORK WOULD WRITE A HEADLINE
OR CHOOSE A PHOTO THAT WAS OUT
OF CONTEXT AND YOU WOULD HAVE
WHITE HOUSE REPORTERS OR LET'S
CALL IT "THE NEW YORK TIMES" IS
HYPOTHETICAL.
THEY WOULD CALL UP AND SAY
THAT'S NOT WHAT HE WAS SAYING.
THAT'S NOT WHAT HE WAS DOING.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT HAPPENED HERE.
POSSIBLY COULD'VE HAPPENED BUT
IT CAN HAPPEN SOON ENOUGH.
SOME OF THE OUTLETS LIKE THE AP
DELETED THE TWEET WHICH IS
BETTER THAN NOTHING BUT IT DOES
SHOW YOU THAT IMMEDIATELY THEY
HEARD "ANIMAL" AND "IMMIGRANTS,"
I MAY PUT IT TOGETHER WITHOUT
CONTEXT.
I WANT TO MAKE A POINT THAT IT,
THE PRESIDENT ON THIS ISSUE.
ED GILLESPIE WHEN HE WAS RUNNING
FOR GOVERNOR OF VIRGINIA, ONE OF
HIS ISSUES WAS MS-13.
"THE WASHINGTON POST" HAD
SEVERAL HEADLINES.
IF WE HAVE THEM, WE CAN SHOW YOU
IF WE HAVE THEM, WE CAN SHOW YO
YOU.
BASICALLY DESCRIBING ED AS A
RAPIST, POISONOUS.
A MONTH LATER
"THE WASHINGTON POST" ALL OF A
SUDDEN HAD A CHANGE OF HEART
ABOUT MS-13 IN THEIR HEADLINES.
AFTER ED GILLESPIE LOSES THEY
TALK ABOUT HOW I MISS 13 IS
TERRIBLE.
THEY ARE VIOLENCE.
A COUPLE EXAMPLES.
IT'S VERY INTERESTING THAT THAT
THE MEDIA TENDS TO DEFEND MS-13
IN THE STRANGEST WAYS IN ORDER
TO HURT A REPUBLICAN.
IT'S AN UNFORTUNATE SET OF
EVENTS.
HERE'S THE THING.
THIS HELPS TRUMP.
>> Jesse: IT DOES.
>> Dana: YOU DON'T WANT THIS
TO HAPPEN TO ANYBODY BUT AT THE
END OF THE DAY, HER     HE CERTA
END OF THE DAY, HER     HE CERTN
END OF THE DAY, HER     HE CERTY
WON.
>> Jesse: SOME PEOPLE ON
TWITTER SAYING EVEN MS-13
MEMBERS AREN'T ANIMALS.
THEY ARE HUMANS.
TAKING A LITTLE TOO SERIOUSLY.
>> Greg: THEY HAD TO SHIFT,
ONCE THE STORY FELL APART, THEY
HAD TO FIND A NEW AVENUE.
NOW THEY ARE DEFENDING A
MURDEROUS GANG OF RAPISTS.
MS-13 IS ANOTHER VICTIM CLASS.
IF YOU GO AFTER THEM, YOU ARE
THE BAD GUY.
HOW DARE YOU JUDGE.
THEY ARE JUST IT, THEY ARE LIKE
A BOOK CLUB WITHOUT THE BOOKS.
THIS IS THE LAUREL-YANNY
EXPERIMENT WRIT LARGE.
NORMAL PEOPLE HEARD WHAT THEY
HEARD CORRECTLY WHICH WAS HE WAS
REFERRING TO A GANG.
THE MEDIA HEARD RACIST.
IT IS THE LAUREL-YANNY EXCEPT
THAT THEY ARE MISHEARING THIS ON
PURPOSE.
THIS ISN'T AN ACCIDENT.
I GUESS MAYBE BECAUSE OF THEIR
OWN CONFIRMATION BIAS THEY ARE
SELECTIVELY HEARING SOMETHING.
AND IN THE NECK STRATEGY IS,
THEY KNOW THEY'RE WRONG, THEY
KNOW THEY MADE A MISTAKE.
THEY ARE GOING TO SAY IS TRUMP
HAS SAID BAD THINGS BEFORE.
HE WILL PROBABLY SAVE THEM
AGAIN.
SO IT DOESN'T REALLY MATTER THAT
THEY ARE WRONG HERE.
THAT'S THE SAME ARGUMENT THEY'VE
USED DEFENDING HATE CRIMES.
THE RACIST GRAFFITI WAS FAKE BUT
SOMEWHERE AROUND THE COUNTRY IT
IS REAL.
IT'S THE LAST ARGUMENT THEY ARE
GOING TO HAVE TWO DEFEND IT.
IT'S GOING TO BE HILARIOUS.
I WILL GIVE TIME TO OTHER PEOPLE
I WILL GIVE TIME TO OTHER PEOPL
PEOPLE.
>> Jesse: AS SARAH SANDERS
MENTIONED ENDED A VERY GOOD JOB
OF MENTIONING, THE AMOUNT OF
HEINOUS CRIMES COMMITTED BY
MS-13, KIMBERLY.
YOU'VE HAD EXPERIENCE WITH THEM.
I DON'T SEE HOW THE DEMOCRATS
CAN EVEN GO NEAR AGAIN LIKE
THAT.
>> Kimberly: ABSOLUTELY.
OVER THE YEARS, WORKING AT A GET
-- AS A GANG CRIME SPECIALIST.
THIS IS A PRIME EXAMPLE OF MEDIA
BIAS EXPOSED.
YOU SEE A SITUATION LIKE THIS
BECAUSE THE LEVEL OF VITRIOL
THAT THEY HAVE AND THE ANGST AND
UPSET TOWARDS THE PRESIDENT,
THEY TOOK IT TOO FAR AND THEY
TRIED TO SAY IT'S A SITUATION
WHERE HE IS BEING RACIST TALKING
ABOUT THIS.
I DON'T THINK THE PRESIDENT TOOK
A FAR ENOUGH SAYING ANIMALS.
WHEN YOU SEE THEIR HANDIWORK AND
YOU SEE THE CRIME SCENE AND YOU
SEE PHOTOS OF ME TALKED THE
FAMILY MEMBERS OF MS-13 AND THEY
ARE COMMITTING HEINOUS
ATROCITIES SHOWING NO REGARD FOR
HUMAN LIFE.
USE OF THE MACHETE.
THEY LOVE TO PUT NAILS ON
BASEBALL MASTER BEAT PEOPLE TO
DEATH.
THE YOUNG GIRL, TEENAGER WHO
THEY FELT DISRESPECTED COME.
THAT GANG LEADERS SHRINE TO A
DEMON.
FAMILY MEMBERS NOT ABLE TO
IDENTIFY THE CHILDREN BECAUSE
THE STATE OF THEIR BODIES THAT
THEY ARE LEFT IN.
NOT EVEN ANIMALS.
WILD ANIMALS EVEN BEHAVE LIKE
THIS.
WHEN YOU REALLY THINK ABOUT THE
FACTS ABOUT WHAT THE PRESIDENT
WAS SAYING, HE WAS SAYING
RESPECT FOR VICTIMS, RESPECT FOR
LAW ENFORCEMENT AND A FLAT OUT,
SAYING I HAVE NO TOLERANCE FOR
HEINOUS CRIMES COMMITTED, AND I
LOOK TO PUBLIC SAFETY AND THE
LAW ENFORCEMENT TO DO SOMETHING
ABOUT THIS.
>> Jesse: JUAN, YOU'VE WORKED
IN THE MAINSTREAM PRINT MEDIA
BEFORE.
ANY EXCUSE FOR SOMETHING LIKE
THIS?
IS IT SLOPPINESS OR IS IT
SOMETHING MORE?
>> Juan: YEAH, IT IS CALLED
ACCURACY.
>> Jesse: WALL, WHAT DO YOU
MEAN ABOUT THAT?
>> Juan: IT'S ACCURATE.
YOU ARE FEEDING THEIR GRIEVANCES
ON THE RIGHT BY SAYING THE
TERRIBLE MAINSTREAM MEDIA, HOW
COULD THEY SAY SOMETHING SO
AWFUL.
THEY MISINTERPRETED THE
PRESIDENT.
YOU KNOW WHAT, THE PRESIDENT
CALLED PEOPLE ANIMALS.
AND THEN YOU SAY OH, NO, NO, IT
WASN'T PEOPLE.
HE WAS REFERRING TO THE
HANNIBAL LECTORS OF THE WORLD,
MS-13 GANG.
YOU KNOW WHAT, YOU DO NOT TALK
ABOUT OTHER PEOPLE AS ANIMALS.
I DON'T CARE WHO YOU ARE OR WHO
THEY ARE.
YOU DO NOT BECOME A MONSTER BY
DEMONIZING YOUR OPPONENT.
[ALL SPEAKING]
HOLD ON.
I WANT TO FINISH.
I THINK THEY ARE TERRIBLE BUT --
>> Greg: YOU CALLED THEM
TERRIBLE!
HOW INSULTING ARE YOU!
HOW DARE YOU CALL THEM TERRIBLE?
IT'S HURTFUL.
>> Juan: I CALL YOU HILARIOUS.
HERE'S THE THING.
YOU HAVE A PRESIDENT WHO SAYS
THAT PEOPLE WHO ARE COMING TO
THIS COUNTRY WHO AREN'T WHITE
ARE COMING FROM S-WHOLE
COUNTRIES.
YOU HAVE THE PRESIDENT TALKING
ABOUT BOOK COMING FROM MEXICO.
MURDERERS, RAPISTS.
THIS IS THE KIND OF EXCUSE YOU
HERE FROM THE RIGHT WING ECHO
CHAMBER.
I AM TELLING YOU.
YOU GUYS ARE TRUMP APOLOGISTS
TODAY BECAUSE THE PRESIDENT.
>> Greg: OH.
>> Jesse: YOU ARE A FAKE NEWS
APOLOGIST, JUAN.
TAKEN OUT OF CONTEXT?
>> Dana: [ALL SPEAKING]
>> Juan: YOU LOVED TO MAKE
IMMIGRANTS INTO EVIL BECAUSE IT
FIRES UP TRUMP'S FACE.
>> Jesse: WE ARE NOT
CONFLATING MS-13 WITH IMMIGRANTS
CONFLATING MS-13 WITH IMMIGRANT
IMMIGRANTS.
>> Kimberly: DID YOU HEAR WHAT
DANA SAID?
>> Greg: THIS LAUREL-YANNY
THING WHICH YOU ARE SEEING RIGHT
HERE IS JUAN HERE'S YANNY WHICH
IS SAD BECAUSE IT'S DEFINITELY
LAUREL.
>> Kimberly: I HEARD LAUREL.
>> Greg: IT'S A VALUABLE
LESSON ON THE HELP WE LEARN FROM
IT.
A COUPLE WEEKS AGO, SOMETHING
CHRIS HAYES DID FROM MSNBC WHICH
I THOUGHT WAS PRETTY ADMIRABLE.
TRUMP WAS TALKING TO PARALYMPIC
ATHLETES AND HE SAID HE WANTED
TO WATCH THEM PERFORM BUT HE
FOUND IT HARD.
THERE WAS A GROUP OF PEOPLE THAT
SAID HOW DISGUSTING IT WAS THAT
HE WAS SAYING HOW HARD IT WAS TO
WATCH PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES
PERFORM.
ACTUALLY WHAT HE WAS SAYING IS
IT'S HARD TO WATCH BECAUSE HE IS
BUSY.
AS THE PRESIDENT, IT'S HARD FOR
HIM TO WATCH THE OLYMPICS OR
PARALYMPICS.
CHRIS HAYES ORIGINALLY TWEETED
OUT THAT THIS WAS DISGUSTING.
HE WANTED AGAIN -- WATCHED IT
AGAIN.
HE SAID I WAS WRONG.
HE WAS TALKING ABOUT THE
SCHEDULE.
IF PEOPLE GO AND LISTEN, IT'S
OBVIOUS HE IS TALKING ABOUT A
HE IS CALLING THEM ANIMALS.
EVERYBODY KNOWS THAT.
PEOPLE HAVE TO LEARN THAT MAY BE
THEY HAVE TO STEP OUT OF THEIR
OWN DELUSIONS, THEIR OWN
EMOTIONS AND RELIES THAT YOUR
INITIAL RESPONSE IS INCORRECT.
>> Juan: DO YOU THINK ANYONE
WHO IS A CRIMINAL IS AN ANIMAL?
>> Greg: I THINK THAT'S
INSULTING TO ANIMALS.
BY THE WAY, WE ARE ALL ANIMALS.
>> Juan: I THINK IN OUR
SOCIETY LOTS OF PEOPLE WHO ARE
JUDGED GUILTY OF CRIMES LATER
RETURN AND WE WANT THEM TO --
WE DON'T SAY THEY ARE ANIMALS.
>> Greg: THEY ARE NOT, ARE NOT
THESE ANIMALS?
>> Juan: I LIKE WHAT GREG
SAID.
CHRIS HAYES.
I THINK PEOPLE MAKE MISTAKES.
REMEMBER WHEN THE DOCTOR
KING STATUE THEY SAY WAS REMOVED
FROM THE OVAL OFFICE AND THEY
HAD TO CORRECTED.
PEOPLE IN MEDIA MAKE MISTAKES
BUT THIS IS NO MISTAKE.
>> Dana: IT HAPPENS THE OTHER
WAY TOO.
I DON'T KNOW ALL THE DETAILS BUT
THE CORRESPONDENT ON CNN.
THERE WAS SOMETHING ABOUT A
GRAPHIC.
SAYING THAT THEY PUT A TARGET
OVER PRESIDENT TRUMP.
SAYING NO, I DIDN'T BUT IT HAD
ALREADY GONE HALFWAY AROUND THE
WORLD.
IT HAPPENS ON BOTH SIDES.
>> Greg: IT IS JUST WORSE ON
THEIR SIDES.
>> Jesse: THEY ARE GETTING ALL
OF THESE NEWS STORIES WRONG.